I'm noticing people beginning to
self-organize in two different camps
people who seem to be able to respond
with a kind of integrated personality
that generates creativity creative acts
creative responses and another camp that
is feeling deeply hopeless and is trying
to substitute the old life with some
other kind of an ordering process to
eliminate uncertainty trying to
excessively prescribe how to think and
how to act so this idea of moving
forward into this creative relationship
to the self or regressing backwards into
whatever kind of a structured determined
system that can restore a sense of
safety
now those two things may be in each
person to some degree but I'm noticing
camps begin to settle out in those two
categories which is worth tracking I
think so it's interesting I you're you
know the meaning I'm making of what
you're saying is the theme of how we
make meaning that we need narratives we
need storylines and if perhaps we can
stay in the don't know and the
uncertainty we may find some creative
Wellsprings within ourselves or our
immediate surrounds and be able to
respond proactively in some way
internally and perhaps externally if we
don't have that we may revert to
internal and external sort of
authoritarian structures and narratives
that that this is and there are those
out there there are conspiracy theories
and all kinds of things in order to have
some kind of meaning making
structure that's often external rather
than internal yeah and you know that
that goes to Jung's religious function
of the psyche right that our psyche is
built to need meaning and that the need
for meaning and the drive to find
meaning is a fundamental ordering
principle of the human psyche and we're
traditional meanings have been swept
away were the things that kind of kept
us tethered to an orderly life are
suddenly taken off the table we will try
to fill that vacuum and one place that
we might reach will be a kind of
authoritarianism whether it's kind of
self-imposed or we reach to find it out
in the collective and it can be an inner
authoritative figure absolutely yes we
regress back to some kind of a belief in
a set of rules which has never really
been adequately questioned or somehow
comes from a very early part of our
lives that can over time be rather
suffocating although in the short term
it feels relieving